absolute haus folgen hier geht warum ich
bin ich pro medium
nein ich bin wieder unten das ist doch
das kann doch nicht bei euch auch hier
unten
hallo ich im freunde und willkommen zu
petrol part 8 zusammen mit dem bariton
nicht mehr schnell minecraft hexen so er
muss erst mal ganz kurz in minecraft das
ist nicht und hier gerade ein
unsichtbarer bakulin habe ich am ende
von long es folgen noch eben schnell
geschafft da musst du einfach die lücke
wenn du schaffst das schon ganz gut eine
lücke ist ein bisschen tricky das muss
ich jetzt schon sagen ich hoffe das
schaffst du nicht was muss man bestimmt
die reste teleport und jetzt ist ein
pfeil check check check point juhu ich
freute mich mal voll wenn dieses
checkpoint in kommt obwohl die
entwickler in springe ich meine wir sind
eben gerade gestorben in meiner folge
und wir waren einfach wer beim sparen
wir werden nirgendwohin checkpoint war
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt kommt
blöcke gehen sie sind an und ja sehr
merkwürdig dass just crazy metten komme
rede darauf englischen die englischen
zuschauer interessant kommt einer von
euch das england das ich cool egal
helfer closer look at diesen notfall
alarmiert da guckt mobil episch ist dass
der fisch es regnet einfach die coolste
im das echt cool gemacht
du kannst du was das jetzt soll ich für
totilas ist thomas schaaf bat wo michael
jackson hat funktioniert das toll
wirklich wirklich der check manama
geklappt
hallo hier sind hinten fische und die
greifen mich an und das ist ihm glaube
ich dir gott so gut wie keine andere das
sind schreibens in wirklichkeit das ins
landratsamt ok lampl solide in shampoos
ein bisschen sicherheit
ich hoffe ich habe mich da man dieses
campus denke ich habe viel lieber als
mit machen wir sind jetzt nicht doch
über als witz überall was soll ich
machen
verdammte scheiße drei herzen
ich bin von der insel runter gefallen
wohl in shampoos
shampoos ein bisschen aber das ist
hinter mir her und zombies und ich komme
kurz wieder zu dir alter sind hier viele
leute wo müssen wir denn hin
wir müssen wieder machen wohnungslücke
die die schubst mich aber die ganze zeit
weg sind so viele mops gerade hat er
weder von der plattform runtergefallen
ja ich auch verdammte kacke und die
kommen auch irgendwie überall mit was
ging hier gehabt die haben resistenz na
ja englisch oder sowie sterben sich aber
die drängen so stark weg ich habe es ja
ich wollte dass das extra so dass wir
ihre sprungkraft haben und resistent
passieren nicht töten aber weißt du wo
ich glaube den servern verabschiedet
sich gleich ich geh mal kurz wieder zu
dir weil wenn ich mich jetzt halt
unbedingt diesen effekt ich wenn ich
deine hätten hin laufe ich habe mich
einfach umgebracht
der effekt war warum bringen keine gute
idee
ich musste ich jetzt irgendwie wieder
nach hinten hin bringen
ich schaffe es nicht london
ich bin traurig für mich getroffen ich
versuche hochzuschalten ist gedrückt
kann richtig hoch bringt ich hab ja ich
meine alten plattform ich bin auf dem
häuschen
da sollte doch das salz auf die andere
oder touchpen ich jetzt drauf nein diese
bis teile alter bisher überhaupt nicht
so jung und schon wieder gefallen
ich hab's geschafft meine sprungkraft
das weg gegangen
die rennen nun einem yuen dem moment
meine sprungkraft das weg gegangen genau
in dem moment wo ich gebraucht habe
registrieren
ach so wie möglich wieder nach oben
ok jetzt sagen so jetzt auch noch mal
ein versuch so schwierig ist es gar
nicht was ich jetzt mache ich habe ja
noch dieses resistenz ich wohne jetzt
die neue sprungkraft ja jetzt stoppt in
dem ich schon das ist doch unfassbar
die stop mich schon auf den weg wenn ich
darüber kommen will wo bist du denn ich
bin tot
die greifen mich an auf dem weg schon
ich komme da nicht mehr drüber
du musst den speed boost habe ich ja
aber die stoppte mich schon auf dem weg
lag ja es stimmt ich hätte fast drüber
geschafft das ist richtig doof weil die
übertreibung vorstelle ich meine es ist
interessant zu sehen aber ruhig betrieb
mit und jetzt ratlos
ihr sollt euch ja schon im bus ok ich
auch lasst mich doch ich habe darüber
ich schaffe das jetzt auch nein diese
cups gucken mal zu dabei da kann er
nicht sein
ich muss das noch weiter weg von dem
diese scheiß was so schafft es nicht
hier sind so viele makler cubes komme
ich kann aus justizkreisen response and
richtig viele neue wieder gespannt
ich kann mit kickern versuchen dagegen
anzugehen es ist einfach ich kann ich
spenden daran liegt ok mobile gerade mit
allen mitteln dir zu helfen und banken
angegangen was habe ich hier flip mm wie
ein orden
ich muss etwas ist was passiert
wir warten jetzt welche in den baum es
ist eine absolute herausforderung ich
bin ich pro medium
nein ich bin wieder unten komme das ist
doch das kann doch nicht beust euch auch
hier unten
ich weiß was ich jetzt mache ist mir
jetzt alles hier komm ich strengt euch
alle in die luft ist mir so was von egal
ja so macht man das baby genauso ja
jetzt erst mal ein paar creeper setzen
richtig so jetzt explodiert hier creeper
explodiert hier im jahr an kaputt habe
richtig viel roter gehauen dadurch durch
den körper ich will nur einmal auf den
schalter drücken lassen doch auf den
verdammten so ich habe aufgeregt jetzt
wieder hoch da die auch das ach so jetzt
bin ich auf dem feld ich werde immer
wieder untergeht traurig und ich war
schon so weit
doch wie viele hinter hier macht doch
mal hier dass wir darüber können dort
jetzt ganz kurz freunde mal ganz kurz
mal ganz ruhig hier ich hab's geschafft
ich werde euch jeden fall diese skizzen
in meinem disstrack keine resistenz also
ich hatte gerade eine krankheit und
schon wieder heisse fallen wie viele
sind denn hier
ich hab noch nie so viele squibb diese
andere kacke auf einem haufen gesehen
lasst mich dort auch barney
wahrscheinlich oder macht nix patsche
abklatschen doch nicht neu doch ich
gesehen habe was geht nicht
raps getötet 300 überquere ich gemacht
habe war komplett zu machen war kein
fehler
welchen fehler wo bist du eigentlich
dachte er davon
ich bin ja bei dir und skripte der
wachmann weit muss noch mal machen
du bist einfach verschwunden
so komme ich sehr hoch weil die kammer
auch getroffen märkische irgendwie einen
weg nach oben finden wir dürfen keine
blätter abbauen aber es gibt einen weg
nach oben bei den bauern schon
durchgefallen
ja ich will auch um leute checkpoint
selber was soll s 1 as on sein
laserschwert hier nur vorjahr man
checkpoint checkpoint ist so schön
gerade ich halt einfach immer jeden
knopf weil ich angst habe so kampusch
kreitl jump in die pont in ex agent stan
die nächste insel thule pro ride the
jump in kontakt kommt diese vierzehnten
hast du den schalter umgelegt alter was
geht er mir ja ich glaub was war dann
hast du das gesehen bei mir ich habe nur
gesehen wie du runtergefahren bist
versuchst du mal
wo bist du ich bin in der ich sehe hier
aber gerade so dürfen wahrscheinlich dem
spawn oder sogar die hilfe was bei mir
auch
ja ich komm ich irgendwie das vaters ich
versuche auch noch mal ja also du kannst
das schaffen wenn nur weil ich bringe
mal irgendwo gegen da oben bei mir der
job muss weiß ich bin so hoch und dann
wäre ich direkt wieder runter geholt
irgendwie gar kein schampus sehr gut
sind wir beide hier unten können uns
kurz töten
machst du kurz wo kommst da raus scheiße
du bist ich fliegt er lieber schon gut
ich bin da wo die ganzen schleims sind
effektvoll nicht geklappt
das ist total doof manchmal konzern hier
ja ich bin jetzt bei dir aber das ist
richtig doof man mit dem campus man
kommt damit einfach nicht hier ist doch
kein jump to stay
da ist noch so weit in den export gehen
runter von der insel vielleicht darf man
einer drauf spielen
ich komme nicht mal runter so und
schlecht auch jetzt geht's a m wie ich
weiß nicht was hier gerade verkehrt ist
arbeitet ihr enkel jan zeit jetzt nach
oben gehauen da kenne ich muss ich meine
schnelle finden vielleicht jetzt bist du
hier drauf ist dafür nur ein portal das
ist so komisch mit diesem campus ja
warte ich weiß wie es geht
ich weiß wie es geht muss eben hier
unter ja moment ich gehe unter ok jetzt
ist normal letztlich eine entscheidung
jetzt laufe ich
in dem moment habe ich auf der
hauptplattform da oben wo du jetzt auch
drauf stehst also oft sehr alleine
probieren einmal ja aber wird man durch
ein plug-in grad zurück gepackt ich weiß
es kann aber hier ist nur world drauf
also kein essentials also ok ich hab' 19
sekunden sprungkraft aber ich werde
immer wieder nach unten geholt
vielleicht ist das alles ohne effekt
nennt also man darf ja eigentlich nur
uncool wenn man muss ja eigentlich bin
mal ganz kurz geliftet einmal zu gucken
ob es jetzt irgendwie klappt ich springe
quasi hoch und werde immer wieder nach
unten gut aber eigentlich sollte man ja
nach oben mehr sprungkraft steht ja im
inventar aber eigentlich sollte man
springen können glaube ich und dann halt
so ganz normal sprungkraft und dann
schwingt man rein aber vielleicht
schafft als auch ohne sprungkraft
wie schafft man nicht ich habe eine idee
einer schale schon ja keine ahnung
müssen wir gucken
ich komme jetzt wieder da oben hoch mit
dem hof mit nicht hochkommen ich muss
auch mal nachzuschauen
wir müssen von hier hier bekommen wir
sprungkraft auch so nübel säfte glaub
ich glaube daran liegt dass und wir
werden irgendwie von der welt wieder
nach hinten geworfen
ja und wir fliegen dann hier hin fliegen
hier rein
und dass der insel das ist eher locker
aber ich meine von hier auch ohne
sprungkraft kann man den sprung schaffen
nee das ist eigentlich sollte das ganze
kostet challenge denkt vorindustriellen
dann steht da drauf shampoos try to jump
in front also das packt würde ich auch
sagen achtung gut da würde ich mir
meinen teleportiert euch einfach zu mir
weil dann überstürzen will
wir müssen den überspringt gekommen da
nicht weiter da kam einfach kurz zu dir
ich bin übrigens ein bisschen erkältet
falls ihr euch fragt warum meine nase
ein bisschen rot ist und warum ich ein
bisschen taschentücher immer am rhein
schnäuzen benutzer gut also damals
geschafft hat er weniger okay was ich
jetzt bekommen ab zweifel motto wir sind
das hier für stars es gibt hier einen
schwierigen weg das risiko parcours
client ok auch bei dem ein muster
hochklettern weil man da hab ich jetzt
bevorzugt bestimmt geht das sicherlich
ein punkt der im moment wenn sofort nach
oben wenn dann ist auch die folge ist
also du bist davon
ich bin nicht da also winter fielen
gebrochene welche gibt's dann wohl
müssen wohl einen anderen
disney baby die nächste teil ich bin
wieder bei den tintenfischen des pont
erfolge kommt morgen bei komme wir sehen
uns dann wieder wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich total über eine
bewertung freuen und schreibt mal eure
meinung in die kommentare wie ihr das
findet mit diesem er mit diesem bug was
wird ihr da machen an der stelle weil
wie schätzt ihr das ein paar aspekte
aufwarten könnte das liegen eventuell
genau
gut dann sehen uns in der nächsten folge
morgen wieder deuce